let's see if we can evaluate this
indefinite integral and the clue that
trig substitution might be appropriate
is what we see right over here in the
denominator under the radical in general
if you see something of the form a
squared minus x squared it tends to be a
pretty good idea not always but it's a
good clue that it might be a good idea
to make the substitution x is equal to a
sine theta because if you do that then
this will become a squared minus a
squared sine theta and if you factor out
the a squared you can start leveraging
this is a squared you can leverage one
of the most basic trig identities that
this right over here is cosine squared
theta and maybe simplify the expression
now you're probably saying well this 8
minus 2x squared doesn't it's not as
obvious that it's a squared minus x
squared but we could simplify this or i
guess we can write in a way that it
starts to have this pattern you can
rewrite 8
minus 2 let me write it right under it
you could write 8 minus 2 x squared as
if we factor out a 2 as 2 times 4
minus x squared and now this very
clearly has a pattern a squared minus x
squared you could write this as 2 times
2 squared
minus x squared so in this case a would
be equal to 2.
so let's make that substitution let's
make the substitution that x
is going to be equal to 2
2 sine
theta and dx is going to be equal to 2
cosine
theta
d theta so what's this part under the
expression going to be well we already
started simplifying it right over here
it's going to become
times 2 squared minus x squared x
squared is 2 sine theta so x squared is
going to be 2 squared
sine
theta squared and now we can factor out
the 2 squared so we're going to get this
is going to be 2
times 2 squared
times 1 minus sine squared theta
2 times 2 squared well that's just going
to be 8 times cosine
squared cosine squared theta that's what
we have under the radical so let's do
that let's rewrite this thing up here
so we're going to have
we're going to have i'll take the pi
outside of the outside of the
integration so we're going to have pi
times dx dx is 2 cosine theta d theta so
it's going to be let me make it clear so
dx
i don't want to do that in blue
dx right over there is 2 cosine theta d
theta so let me write that 2 cosine
theta and i'll write the d theta out
here i could have written it in the
numerator and then here in the
denominator i'm going to get the square
root of this business the square root of
8 cosine squared theta so the square
root of that is going to be two square
roots of two the square root of eight is
two square roots of two so let me write
this so let me make it clear what i'm
doing so this right over here is gonna
be the square root of this which is two
square roots of two that's the square
root of eight and the square root of
cosine squared theta is going to be
cosine theta
cosine
cosine theta now you might be saying hey
wait if i take the square root of
something squared then wouldn't that
just be the absolute value of cosine
theta in order to take away the absolute
value i would have to assume that cosine
theta is positive but we can we can make
that assumption that cosine theta is
positive because if we look at this part
if we look right here at this part of
our substitution if we wanted to solve
for theta you divide both sides by 2 and
you'd get x of 2 is equal to sine of
theta or we could say that theta is
equal to arc sine
arc sine of x over 2. now the arc sine
function as it is traditionally defined
will return a theta that is between pi
over or between negative pi over 2 and
pi over 2 and in that range cosine of
theta is always going to be positive so
we can we don't have to write the
absolute value we know cosine theta is
positive
so now we can start to simplify it
cosine theta cancels out with cosine
theta this 2 cancels out with this 2. we
could bring this square root of 2
outside and so we are left with
pi over this square root of 2
over the square root of 2 times the
indefinite integral of just d
theta and this is just going to be equal
to pi over
the square root of 2
times
times theta
plus c and we're almost done we just
have to rewrite this in terms of x and
we already know that theta is equal to
arc sine of x over 2 so we can say that
pi
this indefinite integral or the
antiderivative of this expression is
going to be pi
over the square root of 2
times arc sine
arc sine of x over 2
plus c and we're done some people don't
like a square root of 2 in the
denominator if you want to remove it you
can multiply this by square root of 2
over 2
square root of 2 over square root of 2
and that will simplify it but right now
i just leave the denominator in
irrational form and this right over here
is our antiderivative